- [Narrator] When you
think of Japanese cuisine,
a few foods come to mind.
Sushi, did you know that salmon
sushi is actually Norwegian?
- [Narrator] Yeah, we
did a story on that one.
- [Narrator] Maybe you think of mochi?
- [Narrator] We did that one, too.
- [Narrator] And tempura, but, guess what?
Tempura is actually a Portuguese dish.
- [Narrator] Oh, boy, here we go.
- [Narrator] The Japanese tempura
you know is done two ways:
either with seafood or with vegetables.
- [Narrator] Right, and
the batter is light,
made with cold water,
wheat flour and egg.
Pretty standard.
- [Narrator] This tempura
can be found dating back
to the end of the 16th century in Japan.
- [Narrator] But as we know,
Japan is much older than that.
So, why did it suddenly show up?
The answer is:
- [Both] Portugal!
- [Narrator] Around 1543,
a Chinese ship with three
Portuguese sailors got off course
and landed in Japan on Tanegashima island.
- [Narrator] Fast forward
a bit, and the Portuguese,
because of this happy accident,
are now trading goods, and
arms, with the Japanese.
- [Narrator] Then, in 1639,
the Portuguese were
kicked out of the country.
A few things, however, remained,
including a dish of
battered and fried beans
called Peixinhos da Horta.
- [Narrator] That's Manuela
Brandão, chef at Pap'Açôrda,
one of the best spots in Lisbon
to get Peixinhos da Horta.
- [Narrator] Now, of course,
over the past 400 years,
Japan has put its own spin on the dish,
but, you know, it's a fun fact next time
somebody in your group orders tempura.